le pli de là qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire plan local pour l'insertion
et l'emploi
le pli est porté par une association qui
dans le nord-ouest du département
s'appelle à tout prix nord-ouest 91 le
pli rassemble tous les acteurs publics
qui se soit l'état que ce soit la région
le département les communes des
intercommunalités qui va le mettre leurs
forces en commun au service des
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée au
service de toutes les personnes qui sont
très éloignées de
de l'emploi
nous y travaillons depuis 2011 notamment
à travers la signature de la charte des
clauses sociales qui a été d'ailleurs
renouvelé en septembre de l'année
dernière est prolongé jusqu'au 31
décembre de cette année en attendant la
signature d'une nouvelle charge
il ya un travail impressionnant qui a
été fait puisque à l'heure où nous
parlons depuis l'origine de cette charte
nous avons réussi à générer 7 185 mille
heures de travail ça représente donc
plus de 2000 personnes de 1100 personnes
très précisément qui ont pu accéder donc
un emploi grâce à ces clauses sociales
donc ce que nous souhaitons bien entendu
c'est continuer notre action dans le
cadre du nouveau paysage intercommunal
est mobilisée continuer à mobiliser nos
forces sommes sur un territoire
exceptionnel un territoire en devenir un
territoire où déjà les forces
économiques en présence sont extrêmement
puissante mais un territoire en devenir
tout le monde le sait sur ce grand
plateau de saclay et nous savons qu'il
ya un grand nombre de chercheurs
d'ingénieurs de techniciens supérieurs
qui vont travailler ici de même qu'un
certain nombre d'enseignants mais il y a
aussi des emplois et beaucoup d'emplois
pour des personnes qui sont très
éloignées et nous sommes une charge et
bien entendu de mettre en relation ces
personnes de leur propose également un
parcours d'accompagnement renforcé de
telle façon qu'elles puissent accéder
aux emplois générés par la puissance
économique de ce territoire
je